okay people who are joining this meeting
this is part of our series of meetings
on language completeness and consistency
fourth language and it's a variety of
things we'll be discussing today all
right let's start off with random
instance um
okay so what I was muted I was trying to
remind you so as it says here we
discussed this in our last meeting which
was a while ago because of the
Thanksgiving holiday and there was this
question of you know where does sort of
random instance fit into this family and
you know sort of you know it has such a
general name but right now it's really
restricted to the planar geometry so the
question is what would be more general
right but I think random instance is
you've got a the two possibilities
you've got a constraint or you've got a
symbolic description of a class and both
of those I can imagine a random instance
for you so what does a random mean
you're you usually have some
probabilistic measure to that we you
know generate random things with respect
to so it's a good point I mean you know
something like a random graph it's very
complicated to know what you mean by
that because it's like even okay so it's
like random integer without for example
we could imagine okay we could imagine a
situation where one is able to say for a
data type random instance of you know
type specifier
ah integer 64 or something well actually
that is doable that's doable because
it's a finite set right 64-bit integers
are a finite set right so okay so this
just to remind you of where we were
right we were talking about the
relationship between find instance and
random instance yes okay
right between instance take some sort of
boolean expression and you know gives
you something that you know so I mean if
I say find instance P and Q equals
equals true P Q what's it gonna do what
the hectare equals it's not a boolean
clue
so you'd have to say equivalent what but
this fine instance here is for equal
signs it's over the numeric domain okay
but I don't see why I shouldn't why
can't I do what I just did oh if you say
equivalent or just P and Q will do it I
think this should work is there a good
reason this doesn't work well we we
usually consider equal to be numeric and
equivalent to B to be boolean but I mean
equal sign works so here's a detail well
yeah I I would claim that this should
work just as a courtesy
but yeah the more interesting case okay
so find instance has no guarantee to any
kind of you know well I mean one a one
feature is that for the fourth argument
let's see
instance is is is being given variables
what does random instance do it is very
good at getting back to that thing that
didn't work yeah isn't the president's
order meaning that you were doing P and
Q is true yes oh that's a totally screwy
okay that's totally screwing still
doesn't work but but yeah um okay let's
let's take it what the heck
okay that's a bug in the eye that that
was there yesterday that bug in version
12
you
you
okay random instance and that it finds n
instances now notice that in find
instance you're having to explicitly
give settings for variables right in
other words in this case you're
returning settings for variables whereas
random instance is just taking the
object and finding an instance of that
object right
but the difference is that the only
thing that random instance currently
understands has its own variable
declaration oh I see
so you know I don't think that's and I
mean Ian can correct me if I'm wrong but
unless you well I guess it'll work it'll
just give you the same thing if all the
variables have values is that true so if
I give that geometric scene and then I
say random instance of that geometric
scene it will fill in a B and C for you
right right now if you take that input
sorry that output and call random
instance on that presumably that will
work but will give you the same object
because it's already been all the
variables have been filled in right
there's not the right behavior yes okay
it's a you can also throw in some of the
variables and/or exhibition a question
why is it the case that for algebraic
variables that we don't need this kind
of fully encapsulated form or it isn't
useful would it be useful because we are
typically interested in the value of is
not in the object which it will be
trivially a set of clues I suit you say
so explain to me from a firm first
principle so to speak why that's
different from geometry in other words
in geometry we don't care about
I mean yeah explain
well one thing is for geometry some of
our variables refer to points which are
vectors and some are friends that refer
to scalars so we need to differentiate
that yeah but that that seems kind of
trivial yes but we have vector and
scalar variables in other places I mean
so I guess I mean I mean I would say
that undoubtedly some of it is you know
just legacy right that people are used
to just typing in equations and not
declaring ahead of time what you know
what's what's a variable and what's not
right but no is he I see here that this
legacy but legacy from the 70s and
eighteenth century that we are used to
solve equation also then seeing equation
as an abstract representation of an
ideal and considering the idea that's
nothing what we typically do in their
life when geometry we look at the
geometric figure and end there right so
where where else is there where one does
that so in other words I think another
one where we do it and there we broke
around is Isthmus and importances like
we have an upstart anymore tests and we
call random function you get a concrete
one that is discretized but one could
also imagine that random portes would be
instantiated to concrete random pass and
stage so let's say we say this that's
right I mean then we say how do we get a
random instance of this so I believe
whoops
sense by the way this should work random
walk process of no arguments should be
the D equal probability of either side
so can somebody make a note of that okay
um all right so here so now if I say
random function
this is a case where we could
potentially what the heck no absolutely
and what does that mean
0:10 okay this was out kinda it's no
longer how do I do this I don't say
dateless plot or something that's just
totally weird how do I get the plot of
this like what do you mean the part of
that I mean I want to see the random
walk okay so this is just with different
labels so I mean this random instance
and random I mean if I say random so
we've got random variate of normal
distribution for example comma 10 or
something like this that's random with
respect to the normal distribution so
what we've got is this case where there
is a symbolic representing where there's
a symbolic representation and another
case where there's a constraint
defining city well I'm a little confused
by
in a sense you could imagine a
distribution that
I mean this is a specific instance of
something picked from a distribution
somehow how does this relate to learn
distribution in in machine learning
anybody know anybody here know about
that stuff um don't think so
should I store this Sushma do you know
where I should store this from there is
a muslin miscellaneous folder that was
where I was thinking of - yeah okay
so let's call this random instance um
okay so in the machine learning case I
could say learn distribution
let's do an example here web image
search favorite animal ostrich vicious
creatures if you've never met them I
have seen them I've never actually
personally had a discussion with one and
you know well they come and pick up your
car rather vigorously so is this well
that's because cars were not something
they were evolved to deal with mmm-hmm
who knows um the question is in the mind
of the ostrich what is the car and what
does that question even mean um if this
works I don't know what happened there
something by the way certainly you
should report that bugs it's probably
some version 12 issue okay this is not
good
humpf I mean just for the sake of I mean
maybe it's maybe the ostriches were
vicious and nevermind okay so it was all
I want to get here is a learn
distribution because again I think
that's gonna be another symbolic
representation of
yeah hum of a thing um but but the
thought of it is more or less a
distribution if you learned it or not
yeah I guess that's the case okay so
what other examples do we have okay so
we've got two cases we've got the case
of a set of constraints you know
randomly satisfy a set of constraints
and we've got randomly sample from a
symbolically defined distribution I feel
like there's and a bright line between
these two so so are you claiming that
the first case is random instance or
find yeah I'm coming
I'm claiming that in this case here what
I'm expecting is that both okay so let's
understand both find instance and random
instance could be instances of this but
I think find instance should have a
preference for a simple case right so
find instance is unless you well and
correct me if I'm wrong but find the
instance is deterministic unless you ask
for more than one instance I believe or
maybe they're a small set of cases which
are random wait wait wait it's not
always deterministic saying the same
instance but which may may or may not
use a random generators algorithm
somewhere or well but but shouldn't we
shouldn't find instance by default have
random seating one two three four or
something so there it is at least
nominally the feministic widget in which
it may so it has a random seating option
if you look at the examples are the
options examples but its own it's only
hope it hope it's documented here random
seating yes okay so it has a one two
right but but
the random seating is only used if you
ask for more than one value and what
happens if we only ask for one time
later then is the category so you know
it uses random sitting if it uses
randomized algorithm if you choose a
deterministic algorithm okay but so the
goal of find instance is when there is a
notion of a simplest instance to find it
will do its best to do that is that
correct
nope it will find one instance that's
but but you know nominally that would be
I mean like like for example for this
equation one could imagine that there
are huge solutions to this equation
right right
and I don't know what for so financed
and somehow is is returning solutions oh
wow it doesn't return so that's all it
can return ok let's let's not put in
that constraint then let's see what it
does great it hangs what's it doing well
maybe we should try a smaller case it
probably gets a lot of research
solutions okay I am officially confused
so it so it so I can tell exactly what
it does so it it gets the symbolic
representation of whole solution and
then it randomly generates the integers
that appear in the solution from some
preselected upper bound for it for the
random integer but see means in this
particular case the integers appear in
exponents you will get pretty large
solutions so if they were chosen to be
random integers from between 0 and 1000
then and they were in exponents then
your so why are they an expert because
that's that's the general solution if
you if you saw just to reduce of it oh I
see I see it's a pail equation of some
kind other question yeah ok
but so if I were to make this like an
elliptic curve type jiggy thing huh
that's disappointing
okay say they pretty quickly become a
solo okay I thought there was an
algorithm for all up to curve cases we
have bail equation cases so you will
have to have homogeneous equations I
understand I understand but I'm just
saying I thought that in the world that
elliptic curves had been solved yes it
has been yes and isn't isn't the system
that we're using for doing crypto stuff
isn't it oh I see that's the generation
well does that contain I mean that
contains finding a random point on a
little uptick curve right
the the libraries were using for
cryptography I mean this whole business
this if I say
curve here that will generate random
points on the selected curve if I'm not
mistaken that will solve this problem
you guys are silent generically yes it's
doing that but whether that's you know
how it does it or how general the class
of elliptic curves you can deal with I
don't know I thought it doesn't do this
I thought it does it under additional
constraints for the three factors of x
squared advisory they are not up there
okay well you could ask ask Daria who's
been working on this part of the
cryptography system somebody could ask
her maybe Adam you could ask her okay uh
okay so but but what we imagine I mean
if we said random instance I mean I
would feel quite uncomfortable having
random instance you know being able to
say something like random instance of
that uh I mean we could do this but I
think this is pretty weird I mean in
that the criterion would be that find
instance would try to find the simple
one and random instance would go out
into the wild world and try and find an
arbitrary one whatever that means for
integers right the main use of first
instance is to find one instance the one
that's easiest to find not the simplest
one because the main use is you you try
to decide whether something has
solutions or not okay yeah I mean look
the random instance has some okay for
the geometry case when we say random we
want something that somehow has some
generousity property is that correct
right which is a complete
criterion from what you're asking for
here with finances yes okay well let's
look at some other examples of where we
think we might need these kinds of
things okay
I mean for example does find instance
make any sense for the geometric case if
you're only interested in some of the
variables in principle yes I wouldn't
know why you would be but well you're
suggesting that you would we tell that
in the case of find instance that you
will be giving variables and then it
would extract it would return to you so
the case that you would then be
imagining is in the geometric case you
would be saying something like here I
mean so if I were to take the okay so
I've got this now let's say I want to
extract the value of a variable from
here but wait why does okay so random
instance really is random as in this
it's it's independently seated every
time yeah correct it's implemented with
automatic currently right so what does
that do well I think well there's the
discussion that it should be none
basically what it does is it if you
don't use the random seating option it
goes to it advances to a fine minimum
call and the seedings for fine minimum
are you forgiving using random wheel if
you use random seating then there's a
block random yeah it's whatever random
so holding if I would give a seed random
here or if I were to say block random I
don't know that works what does block
random dude so now I say seed random
first thing will be seen random of
something and then every time I run this
okay I don't understand that
I don't understand that why did that not
the same result because the default
currently implemented is automatic and
automatic means reseed every time which
maybe is not what we want here I think
it's wrong I think we want inherited
don't we you need to be able to
externally seed this random instance I
believe I believe that this is the
behavior you want I mean what does
random variate do it is respect seed
random doesn't it yes well it also
doesn't take a random seating option
okay so question those things that take
a random seeding option some of them are
deterministic they just take one two
three four but the ones that are not
deterministic what do they take sure
which we just look how do we find out
what takes a let's find out how does
Wolfram language data tell us this even
if you just look at the agenda I have
categorization okay so so close so yes
so things that use that randomness will
be yeah so that'll tell you which ones
take them it won't necessarily tell you
what the default is so you'll need to
map options you know options of pound
calm random seating across that result
there
what to call me maybe yeah what now it's
like actually weird yeah I think I think
this is a sick build let's try this one
here what try the second time and see if
it's just a single other load issue well
it says here random seed is not known
option 4 okay so most of them I guess we
should have done pound goes to options
so he was known witch's lives yeah but
first of all why did you pick up ones
but don't have in fact a random seeding
option now it worked so I'm totally
confused by whatever happened here
if there is clearly some sort of
autoloading issue in the machine
learning things right because these were
all machine learning functions that
didn't okay so let's take a look here
image effect that's really random okay
Viktor function is not something that
you call directly normally I think right
I think that's a thing that's produced
so that may just be sort of an oversight
or intentional because I think these are
wrong I think would cloud being random
seeding automatic is wrong I think it
should be one two three four yeah I have
I have I don't disagree with that or
disagree with this you you just you do
disagree yeah I don't want to have every
time the same on it similar to a
dramatic scene I want a different one
really
but didn't Michael I mean you do a word
cloud and you find one that you like and
you go to change the colors and I think
it should be inherited if it's anything
I mean this is after what we modeled it
in geometry sorry what do you okay let's
first of all let's look at the ones here
so some of these like find formula it's
deterministic um alright so net train
has inherited image effect kind of
totally bizarrely has automatic for
reasons I don't understand I seem to
recall there was some bug reporter
discussion or something about this I I
would have to search to get out but yes
I think I agree that this is a little
weird what exactly would inherited mean
from revetted inherited the ambient
stream the this randomness stream so
that is a seed random on the outdoor it
will step up the seed random well does
it block does it do block random does it
leave it in the same state to all these
functions leave the random sequence
random state the same no a they can't do
because inherited must mean do your
random thing because if you call okay if
you call the thing again it will get a
different answers all right the second
time around I'm pretty sure that is true
okay okay so automatic means do your own
thing independent of what was happening
of the seed random in from the outside
right which you know
I mean clearly okay I just don't
understand why you'd want that rather
than inherited no so so okay so
inherently sorry so yeah so I think
these all basically block these all all
these values basically block the random
state so inherited we'll use the current
one but don't you do too if you to do to
write off to each other and they're both
inherited they'll be the same correct
whereas LOC reseed and then unblocked
right and so we talked about this
possibility of a random sitting goes to
none which just means you know to the
extent that that makes sense you know
use the just keep just seed and let you
get your your randomness split out
basically I like that idea
now the question is what should the
settings be all right
other thoughts right and they suppose
the doing of inherited them is you know
if you're doing lots of stuff then
you'll get additional randomness thrown
in or you can sort of set a state using
block random but you know if you do
twice in a row because you're tweaking
things who still get the same you know
the randomness won't change well the
other issue is a completely different
thing which is if you run this function
will you change the random state and
that's super confusing to people because
some of these functions they don't know
that they using randomness I mean
something like find instance you know
they have no idea that they using
randomness so to have something which
doesn't block
the randomness can be very confusing
because you know why on earth would it
change your random state if somewhere
deep inside your code you have a fine
instance right
none of these functions that take or
currently take a random seating option
have random in their name right I
understand
which argues again for ok that argues
against
okay
okay we have a couple of questions on
the live stream which I think we should
answer Carl is asking why are they ever
one two three four that's just so you
get a deterministic answer
um
that is independent of the state of your
random number generator so that every
time you run this function you'll get
the same answer is asking about random
geo position does random geo position
work
is random geo position in there wait a
minute what but what's that why is it in
prototypes backtick I thought we had
this working it's right there
overriding the built-in function Oh drat
okay so somebody needs to report that
bug and that there's that there's a lot
of brokenness here but but okay so
basically yeah okay okay yeah yeah so
that works it's beautiful
okay all right so back to this again so
random geo position for example doesn't
take yes so any function that has random
in its name
you can block random it yes but but if
you don't do that so for example random
instance should really have a random
seating goes to none because it's
essentially a pass-through user of the
random State yeah I agree
okay um okay all right so let's
and so a friend a little bit strange
because obviously there is a kind of
seating you can't do this out the CD
Michael is complaining parent state and
modifying it well is Michael complaining
about the name random seating goes to
none correct
and I think Michael is mistaken because
there is no random seating right you're
not creating you're not doing a block
random you're not setting the seed
you're just letting the normal
randomness of the system persist yes
I mean it's similar random seeding to
inherited is similar to none except that
you are ingesting the randomness from
the external random state alright
somebody else did the seating you didn't
do the seating right but so what's wrong
then with random seating goes to none if
you don't do any seating yeah maybe it's
okay okay alright so that's something we
should add I mean it's gonna be 11 one
may add that I assume um
agreed yeah okay I mean exactly how
widely this can be implemented not sure
okay well I mean bit but well okay fair
enough so that should be looked at but
but okay let's come back to the question
of what the default should be here okay
so the basic principle is if you've got
random in your name then random seating
goes to none if you even have a random
seating option do we agree okay now the
question is things that don't have
random in their name so why image effect
is automatic there
[Music]
you
well I think we might have to ask shoddy
and so on
I like I said I have some recollection
of this being discussed somewhere but I
don't it was long enough ago that I
don't remember the details I'm will need
to ask t image process that's totally
weird
so our note is saying that his he's got
random delete random position random
Roman numeral random Wikipedia data
those are wonderful or no just put them
on the functional posit Ori um those are
great
that is interesting random position is
interesting because it'll go and find a
random position and expression
presumably random Roman numeral is a
little weird I mean okay uh okay so I
want to come back again we don't know
for image effect for imagery style
okay that's seeded I suspect image
effect wants to be a one two three four
seating as well
I think that's just a mistake and
sequence predictor function I cannot
imagine that it wants to be automatic I
think that's probably just an oversight
because you would normally create a
sequence predictor function from
sequence predict and they're just you
know no time so we investigate that um
net train is interesting I tend to think
inherited should it be inherited or
should it be automatic I think we have
to ask a machine-learning folk mmm-hmm I
think inherited is kind of stupid
because it means if you do to net
trainings one after each other you're
gonna get the same answer which you
probably don't want um okay word cloud
what do we have to say about word cloud
so right now if we say you know
something like Wikipedia data of an
ostrich
um and we say word cloud of that hope
this version isn't too broken come on
where is the result come on get back the
result why is this so slow okay there we
go
Wow there are Somali ostriches okay who
knew um yes period is the most one of
the most common words okay so for some
reason this is in fact deterministically
generating which is good I think that's
good I think that's exactly what I want
they don't want this to randomly flip
around my ostriches um I mean I'm happy
with this behavior now the question is
how is that happening if random seeding
is automatic Bret do you want to comment
on this I'm not sure it's possible that
it's the word cloud code is doing its
own interpretation of automatic or
something yeah which is the wrong thing
to do right I think it should be set to
1 2 3 4 since I really do think I mean
Michael you know I mean so so if I say
let's service ok fine then I think we
should let's try this
I think the ostrich is still going to be
in the same place it is so the only
thing that's gonna change the ostrich
probably is if we say random seeding
arrow whatever
as you said the other possibility is
wrong yeah there's a bug Brett what's
that
maybe just use deterministic algorithm
produces well that's an interesting
possibility as well yes um Brett do you
know I don't know off the top of my head
and if you'll recall the word cloud was
originally done by Shah Dee's team so
yes I know I know I know I know
um very useful function I should say
okay well who knows all right well we
gotta track that down but I think what
we agree is random seeding should be one
two three four in this case yeah I think
yes I can't see what it is fine I tree
call on our live stream usefully points
out the predict and classify should have
a similar random seating option which
they whatever whatever is the case for
well whatever is the case for net train
predicting classical I should do the
same thing so okay that's a separate
discussion for yeah call on the live
stream is pointing out about how much
people would like a packet repository us
as well we're working on it it is coming
the function repository solves the
simpler problems um okay let me see how
we'll do these random things work with
undo I think that's totally hopeless get
back to the previous results right so it
doesn't back out the kernel states
exactly yeah yeah I understand but you
can't back out I mean it's no
the case that you can unwind the
randomness stack so to speak there's no
rest once right once randomest has moved
on but what's true is you can undo and
then you can do redo if you want to do
restore what you undid but if you really
ate and obviously you'll get something
different unless you know there was a
block okay so let's go back to the
original question here okay so we are
talking about okay random instance okay
but so the question is okay great
there's that yeah so that they we ignore
that that's just an implementation
detail that needs to be worked on there
the problem one so just ignore it we
discussed it last time what is this and
also we've got the issue in a database
lookup in an external relational
database lookup on how you deal with
randomness there but what is the issue
here the issue here is that we need some
way for the random state of the client
to set random state in the server which
I think we have but maybe we then have
the additional problem of well how does
if this involves a database lookup then
what does this mean so what is your
claim here your claim here is that these
you would expect I would I'm calling a
block random of something called random
entity then I would get the same one
each ten times in a row because I put a
block random around it I see just like
if I put a block random around random
integer of 0 to a million I would get
the same integer ten times in a row yeah
we we have an open pull request to get
random entity and so on - at least on
the Alpha server to support random
seeding the problem is there's an issue
and one of the developers just hasn't
had time to deal with it with getting it
to work with surf packets and so it's
one of these cases where the perfect is
becoming the enemy of the good because
it wouldn't work for all things it would
just work for a lot of things right and
that's basically this but it's not even
that it's a particular it's a particular
it's the semantics it's a particular
rate it's a particular implementation
for you know so so it only it only is
relevant for some entity types and not
for all entity types right but but so
without loss of efficiency you can get
this to work correctly is that what
you're telling me
yes okay so because the folks dealing
with relational databases seem concerned
that there isn't a way to do that if
you've got a relational database with a
hundred thousand entries picking a
random entry apparently is not a typical
operation on the database server but we
yes that's absolutely true but the
different I suspect not having been in
meetings with them for a long time that
the difference between us and them is we
have control of the schema and they're
trying to interact with arbitrary
provided database and so we designed the
schema in order or actually I should say
we redesigned the schema in order to
make random lookups efficient okay I'm
surprised that they can't just well I
don't know how the keying works and the
indexing that they can't just say here's
an X number of entries pick the 213
entry and so on you can say pick the 200
13th century the problem is depending
depending on the schema it might be
inefficient for the database to find the
213 country and and moreover what's the
definition of the 200 well yeah what's
the there might not be
it doesn't matter if you're picking you
know if you're picking with uniform
distribution over the entities in that
database table it doesn't matter what
that but right right but but what's how
do you guarantee that it's a uniform
distribution so what one of the problems
that we had with a previous
implementation of random entity was that
your random country was almost
guaranteed to be South Sudan because of
some weird thing with how the entity
ideas were what you mean South Sudan got
lots of entity IDs for some weird reason
it well the South Sudan has a unique
entity ID but the distribution of entity
IDs were such that the algorithm being
used would often pick South Sudan that's
crazy yeah well I have to say Sudan does
seem pretty random so I guess it lives
up to its name
well it's a new country that's that's
that might have something to do with
wound owes what's happening um yeah
hands on the live stream is suggesting
random integer and then to a select by
row ID I think it's what we're talking
about but there seems well that that's
that's what we implemented except that
there isn't a concept of row ID or at
least at least that's what I was trying
to explain is that row ID isn't always
well-defined
fair enough okay so let's go back to
what we were originally talking about
here which is where else can random
instance be used right and so one idea
that we had last time was that basically
random instance could become like
finding like could be extended to
perhaps be more like find instance and
then find instant right it's going to be
the randomized version of find instance
but a it wasn't entirely clear what it
should return right because find
instance returns the assignments of the
variables and random instance returns
the actual instance right and then the
second question is you know reconciling
the fact that they have different
argument order structures at the moment
well I'm not okay let's let's zoom out
for a minute of things which we think
might be random instance a ball okay and
the two cases that we've talked about
are things defined from a symbolically
defined distribution okay and you know
other than things for which random
variate would apply I don't understand
what we can do with random instance
that's different from random variate for
instance we have something there are no
disappearing can exist for it in this
room we would have a symbolic
representation of all c1 functions
there's no probability measure on c1 yet
obviously there are many functions that
are c1 may not be interesting or useful
but okay there's no reason
okay so let's tipica nother example
let's say Turing machines okay there
isn't a useful distribution so I mean we
could imagine random instance I don't
really know how we represent okay so
there's no numbers would be the easiest
example okay all right but we don't have
a good way okay of rationals we do have
a notion of the of rationals okay
random instance of rationals comma 100
okay so the main the first the main
issue with this is you know it's like
what is a random integer in an unbounded
collection of integers what's what is it
who knows I mean but you don't have a
disabusing we don't have a measure so
what will we do in this case random
instants are irrational
what would we expect to do is there
anything reasonable to do in this case
okay let's talk about why the geometry
case works for an 'm instance the answer
is implicitly although you could imagine
something where you have that triangle
is arbitrarily exotically long or maybe
you can't even imagine that okay if i
say random instance of just a line
between two random instance of two
points what's it gonna do maybe we
should try
see a lot of random points I think one
thing one difference is that we're not
guaranteeing any sort of true randomness
or you know particular distribution
okay so if I just say this and I just
say give me a triangle these what is the
space so okay so that's interesting
competitive compare that with random
polygons so random polygons three would
give me also herbs would give me also
random triangle if I'm not mistaken yeah
okay so is it the case that the
collection if I do a table of ten of
these okay and I do a table of ten of
these am I going to have the same who
knows random polygon is gonna give you I
think much skinnier pot you know
triangles for perhaps okay can anybody
discuss this in or yes because we we
won't we won't form geometric scene
things that look nice so we're seeing
don't get to return of it intentionally
so they look natural there's an explicit
rejections that if you know it's too
skinny or certainly degenerate that
it'll so you know you have some sort of
sensor distribution of some unknown
distribution to begin oh right so by the
way this should be had properties and
relations for both of these functions
just an FYI um okay so how should we
think about this so you're saying boy so
random instance says give me a
reasonable random instance of the thing
it's basically what you're saying
correct and the two differences between
random instance and find instance find
instance is telling me what are the
parameters it's like fine this that's
not like fine distribution fine
distribution gives me a distribution
with parameters filled in correct
whereas find instance
is giving me the parameters right so
find instance can give you an empty
empty list right if you give it find the
instance of X greater than 0 and X less
than 0 then I'm pretty pretty initial
give you an empty list right what
doesn't try to produce any randomness so
it may give you always the same instance
if you like the you just you know you
start just different like find instance
I use if solve Hanks I want to know is
there's a chance there any pair that
will scissors do that I know what to do
we are for an instance I really want
every time to see something different
I'm not happy if I every time get yes
one one to do it and that's it now I
agree I agree but I but the problem we
have is a lot of spaces over which we
could get random instances are very
unbounded spaces for various places
where there is no you know intrinsic
measure that's obvious that we can put
on them is that the right care
of the issue okay so what are some other
examples so I mean we could imagine a
you know a random okay random let's
let's try random Turing machine a
vending function random function of one
variable boy you're reminding me of my
favorite in num see what I can do it yes
I guess one question is there an
advantage to having a random instance
over you know a random geometric scene
and a random Turing machine and so or so
you know you actually have some sense of
what's what you're going what you can
put in and what you might get out what
do you mean sorry I'm so if I have
something called random instants like
random instance of rationals that that
first of all would never occur to me
even if we did support this yes and so
I'm concerned about having this thing
called random instance that certainly at
present only supports one thing and it's
not even clear you know after two
two-hour long discussions we haven't
really identified a larger set of things
that it might you know could clear
larger set of things that it could work
with right I don't think you can put in
a random you know an arbitrary
expression and in random I was just
looking for um hold on one second I was
looking for my oh yeah there we go if
this works just launching some boss
emulator it's launching an emulator of
something I can't know what it's
emulating oh it's but bsd unix okay
ah ah there we go
I'd like to play a game I haven't seen
that out in a while
that's from 1986 this is a bsd unix from
1986 and i have mail I hate to wonder
what that is okay so this is SMP and I
just have to show this because it had a
random expression generator isn't that
the weirdest thing no nobody nobody
wants to comment on how weird Rex is a
random function
yeah yeah yes it's at Rex's that Rex
generates a random expression then um I
wonder whether I can make it let's see
yeah it's the leaf captain I think if I
try and ask for help it will crash um
gosh I don't remember how this works
that is a bad sign
um oh there we go okay so this is
probably if I say this and this is
something totally horrifying because it
oh my gosh that's weird
that's a that's some kind of part
extractor on part of an expression that
doesn't exist I'm surprised it did that
but random position yeah I know I know I
know
um okay so this is on the category of
probably not very useful objects um but
yes I mean the notion of a random
expression
ah
yeah I mean what this was for originally
was partly entertainment of partly
testing but rusty they their indium
composition of of analytic functions the
to the sensible operation right right I
notice pointing out that um
QA has a generate random expression
function which by the way should also
find its way into the function
repository okay so look I think we're
agreeing that this random instance thing
we've got one case where it's useful you
know we will be on the lookout for
additional cases where it's useful but
so far we haven't found one but I don't
think that means we should kill the
concept
a good concept and I think we just have
to be looking for cases where
essentially we have a category of thing
I mean like like for example you know
sorry coming back to my example from
earlier for the head importance right
now the random function of any
importance gives a temporal object but
one could well imagine the venom
instance of an importance gives and the
port says this could decide at a certain
scale that can be say false of this
criticize through the mouth of any means
and it small scales
that seems exotic I mean to me the
problem is we don't have a lot of things
in the system which are self describing
you know which are like like for example
again we could say you know random
instance of rationals as you've said
that could mean something but it's
exotic and we don't know exactly what it
means so there's no difference formal
end imagine this instance would get its
power form there isn't there's a
symbolic object that gets instantiated
yet a symbolic object stays around for
father use yes that's what we're saying
but I mean this is a different case
where look the question is is there
something I mean for example if I said
random instance of and I don't know how
to describe it but it's basically Turing
machines with thumb I mean this would be
useful Turing machines with you know two
states and three colors right there are
whatever it is a half a million of those
and you could imagine just give me a
random one if we had a description an
abstract description of that I mean what
we would be doing there let's take
cellular automata for example I mean
that's something I've wanted many many
times is I mean in my particular case is
something where it's basically this that
means a total istic cellular automaton
well that it's that that pattern thing
isn't really a thing you can do I mean
normally
if I say that it's for example something
like this where I actually have rule you
know this rule and then I can use that
rule on on it on some state but the mean
for the Turing machines I mean you can
just take you know how many there are
you just take care what I mean
exactly although it's a little bit
non-trivial yes but converting that
integer the point is a Turing machine
has a state description but isn't just
an integer well I mean our Turing
machine function can take an integer but
even knowing how many integers there are
for this case isn't trivial you actually
have to kind of look that up in a table
or compute it I mean I think there is a
role that the problem is that we don't
have look random instance could take
type descriptors
right it could take a type specifier
here and if that type specifier I mean
again I don't know what on earth this
means I I think this is a mess I think
this concept is interesting but a mess
and I I propose that what we do is leave
what we have for geometry leave find
instance and simply be on the lookout in
the future for other places well find
that row random instance can be used
that would be my proposal and I think
that makes sense
[Music]
wait all right okay all right sounds
reasonable
um okay so then with respect to this
randomness stuff that is the discussion
that we needed to have for randomness
correct yes okay and we've got some
action items from the Sidra random
seating stuff and so on yeah let's see
if we can very quickly handle some of
these other things here this may be this
this completely different topic area um
I I do need to go um imminently but um
let's try and talk about this remote
file thing in case we can get this
handled quickly um okay so the issue is
we what we'd really like is URL with an
authentication that a true statement yes
because the authentication should travel
with the URL I mean it's not something
that belongs to the function that uses
to you I what is the meaning of remote
file in general it's only purpose is to
be a wrapper to attach the
authentication to the URL in those
functions that use SSH based access like
s FGP and SCP to be like HTTP requests
or it just kind of represents a remote
file or a file on a remote machine
you could connect to with the
information from the URL and the
authentication well KITT so it anyway
okay but but the basic point is and and
and see the reason I mean I don't like
the name remote file because it's not
really the file right it's a particular
way of accessing the file look I think
nobody likes from have fun I think what
we really want is it as an
authentication for URLs and the question
is whether that's going to cause a lot
of trouble I mean I don't I mean it's
probably easy to find out URL is
relatively new how many places there are
I mean the only place that causes
trouble is some sloppy programming well
in that example on the Left where you
have an explicit pattern that allows for
an argument which she's probably common
right and and the other issue would be
is how should it typeset right because
URL only type sets in that pretty blue
form if you have one argument and it's
not clear it should could it have an
opener for the authentication maybe well
I guess the question is should I think
yeah I think it'll be nice to have an
opener for the authentication not least
because in some lazy cases people might
want to put in a URL with visible
username and password in the
authentication you don't want to showed
it by default yes but I think there's a
different issue here I mean the actually
call on a live stream is talking about
putting in headers to spoof things but
those are headers well that's a separate
issue that's that's spoofing things in
the age
P request I think rather than for the
file I mean this this particular thing
is for file operations on remote files
if I'm not mistaken I mean yes I mean
that's the reason for having it but of
course any HTTP URL might also have
these options if you don't want to put
the password into the URL and if you
look at things like URL read or HTTP
request it has lots of these extra
options that are now kind of homeless
wait a second so you're saying if I look
at URL read/write right as all these it
is all these options right which options
this these ones down here so
authentication username there's a few
further up this wall well those are
those are settings for the
authentication option right no no it's
no not here you see here it does not use
your sent occation it has its own
Association of stuff to specify so it's
even though you can't use authentication
down here by the way call on the live
stream is asking if it's just basic
authentication had us no authentication
supports things like permissions keys
secure authentication so secure
authentication is an OAuth
authentication and I think those are
still done via headers though I could be
wrong
I guess there's more than headers
because I know it's unfortunately an
unbelievably complicated back and forth
oh yeah I believe okay but I mean that
doesn't mean I mean if it's if it needs
headers to make it work but that doesn't
mean we have to specify them like that
you could be a bit smarter and just
extracted from the authentication option
that's right but so let's walk through
what you're saying so first point is can
you package in the URL all the stuff
here would you want to package that
stuff in the URL like follow redirects
and so on as opposed to putting it in
URL read and I think there's an argument
that you would want all of those options
down there in the URL read options list
to also be options of URL so you can
pass the thing around because I mean
you're not sure about all of them but
certainly like time constraint is a
perfectly reasonable thing to have in
there I'm not certain about character
encoding follow redirects that's surely
reasonable well but those are convenient
but I think there's a worry that we're
getting too far away from Lee you are a
lob trick there represents a URL those
are convenient to have but maybe not
attributes of the URL well I understand
that but if you're doing copy file the
main issue is exactly so we have a
binary thing that has both both of
options right so right expand
authentication to be like a pair well or
for the case of copy file I mean okay so
what are the possibilities we could have
copy file have authentication take a
list which is source and best what by
then cuz that's a good idea how
complicated would be to to use what I
mean I would just have one thing I
assign that thing to a variable and then
I use that variable in Kapisa and that
thing should not only contain the URL
string but also the authentication and I
mean that follow a directs that doesn't
really apply here because that's kind of
implied that that always happens right I
mean if you fetch a URL you
to follow the widow its unless you have
a specific reason not okay look the main
issue here is we've got our first
example
okay so copy file is a binary user of
URLs everything we've had before is a
unary user of URLs and so we've put the
URL options like authentication and so
on into the function itself right copy
file is our first case where we can't do
that are we going to have other cases of
that and and the way we're dealing with
copy files so I take Romans point that
we want a single object that can
represent a file in some place with its
various authentication you know stuff
around it
I mean the proposal
something like remote file really was
only done because we considered that
having URL extent with options might be
difficult but if that's something they
can do we should although there's the
other issue right so URL has this nice
click button where we passed the URL to
the operating system well I don't know
if we can or should as these other
options to the operating system I don't
know if that's even possible much less a
good idea generally these URLs which are
not as HTTP URLs or FTP or so do not
have a standard operating system program
to open them um I have to go guys um by
the way comments you know the various
comments on the live stream of Brian
about random incidents contain
distributions the problem is cases where
there isn't a distribution like the
rationals and so on and ok back to this
look I think for version 12 we're gonna
have to go with remote file as an
experimental function I don't like it
very much I think we'd be better off
packing stuff in the URLs I think we
should do a study of whether there's a
problem in packing stuff in the URLs and
that's where we should go yeah and I
mean if if you don't want to delay
12-point dog then we shouldn't mess with
you away right now we cannot mess with
URL train has left the station we're not
gonna mess with URL so we will commit
and I will make sure that you remote
file works as indie as intended and make
it experimental then it will show up the
next Doc's meeting okay I mean it seems
to have been documented here yeah it's
not I mean for example a it doesn't even
have to see do to the weight or
Sanitation option that's clearly a back
but right now I see that I see that um
well if you're adding all those options
headers to be set directly that is a
good question why don't we allow and URL
read why don't we allow the headers to
be set because we do because we do allow
them to is that right you know that
these two headers receive but we do have
we must have something to set headers
right yes we can set headers Oh in the
middle in the middle of your document
headers right so so you see you here we
have URL and HTTP and then we have HTTP
request for things which are
specifically HTTP requests I guess so so
comment from call here is what about FTP
for example instead of HTTP see we still
want to authentication for an FTP URL
your FTP is simple because it only
allows username and password and so that
can go into the URL I could be just
remembering but I thought that URL read
supported FTP yes so the question is for
SSH based schemes which have more have
secure more secure and more convenient
ways of authentication like keys and
agents what about so SFTP would be an
example of such yes yes that's part of
the SSH friendly okay but so my question
is so two points here first of all call
is saying shouldn't we allow in
authentication or maybe not even an
authentication just in this collection
of things that we provide here that we
have a thing that is called something
like you know in addition to
authentication that we allow people to
directly set HTTP headers just as a
convenience again we do I don't agree
okay so we do because you can set up the
HTTP request to be whatever you want
right okay for FTP what's the analogous
thing for FTP our own authentication
option would do the right wrapping to
insert username and password or whatever
correct
I mean it shoot him in it right on using
URL read with with FTP then yes I guess
the question is does copy file
understand FTP copy file handles
everything that URL download handles on
the source argument so Paul on our live
stream is making okay so Paul our live
stream is making the point that isn't
all this authentication stuff more than
just the plain URL that if we have a
wrapper called URL I mean this is a
complicated thing right it's a symbolic
wrapper called URL and as a convenience
it can allow more stuff than just the
plain representation of quotes the URL
itself but listen I think for this
version we really don't have a choice
about what we what we have to do um it
is not the perfectly satisfactory thing
I think we really need to investigate
you know generalizing URL but again and
I really would like to also put well
okay yeah all right okay well I guess
I've said this before but I think remote
connection or would be sort of more
accurate name than remote file but any
call other people about that at the
moment it is remote file only and if
it's going away in the future we
shouldn't do we name it before that and
we have a remote connection object but
it doesn't really have something some
way to specify files that's for the SSH
right great an open SSH connection to a
milk machine well are you saying that
this could potentially I see that that's
a stream that allows various streams to
be connected AC okay well I guess we
just live with remote file for now and
either we get rid of
we come up with a better name for me
being wrong but I just remote files
seems wrong yeah I'm not completely
disagreeing with you all right listen
you gotta go thanks everybody here thank
you to folks on the livestream let's use
for comments
talk to y'all soon hey bye